we'll be by Martin Hank from tu Berlin
which I will not try to pronounce but he
will tell us about successive minimum
like inequalities yeah first of all I
would like to thank the organizers or
speak here about so called successive
mini Martire basically what I want to do
is I want to show you some old and new
problems regarding these successive
minima type regarding the success a
Minnie Mouse a they were also introduced
by by Minkowski so again I mean Koski
and actually one can also say that
mainly I will speak about some kind of
generalized stations of makovski serum
which was already introduced by Baidu I
in the first
okay what is my setting well at the
beginning I will speak only a with
respect to that I will speak only about
the intro letter say you can do
everything what I do present so you can
be generalized to arbitrary lettuce but
it doesn't help for the problems I'm
working or I'm living here in the
n-dimensional euclidean space and K sub
n is a space case all convex compact set
and I always assume that they have known
in the moment I will always assume that
they are symmetric with respect to the
origin so just think at the cube of edge
lengths to say centered at the origin
ball something which is nice these are
this is a set of all central symmetric
on Vega bodies and because we introduced
for this class of convex bodies the
so-called successes minima and what this
is for i between 1 and n and the ice
successive minimum is a smallest
dilation factor positive dilation factor
lander with the property if you scale
your body K by lambda then it contains
at least a linearly independent lattice
points
example for instance here we have the
intro lettuce you have a small rectangle
here of edge length 1/2 say and 1 the
origin is the only interior lattice
points lattice point so in order to get
one you have enlarge it and the smaller
sector in this example doing this job
would be the lambda 1 and here lambda 1
would be 2 okay now what is the second
successive minimum now you want to find
two linearly independent lattice points
in your convex what is so again you have
to enlarge it and here is this example
the small specter is 4 and you get this
is lambda 2 times K just want to somehow
find a linearly independent let's clear
so it's yeah and and of course by the
definition they form monotonically
increasing sequence is the smallest one
and maybe lambda 1 is also the most
popular one because you also can say
that this is just the length of a
shortest lattice vector of my lattice
set and with respect to the norm induced
by the symmetric convex body K so if K
is a cubed and it is a maximum norm if K
is across fuller towards the other one
norm whatever okay and now Minkowski
proved two theorems and this is the
first theory regarding these successive
minima and he proved such an upper bound
on the volume so this is just here the N
dimensional a bakery here this 2 to the
N so this is lambda 1 and this is the
inequality this is exactly the theory in
which you have shown which you have seen
in the previous talk maybe this is a :
to the statement that whenever you have
a symmetric convex body of volume
corridor equal to two the end then it
contains a non trivial lattice point if
the volume is greater equal to two the
end then lambda one cannot be bigger
than one in other words it contains the
lattice point so this is for arbitrary
convex bodies now of course as I said
you can generalize it to arbitrary
letters but it doesn't help it's still
the same serum take a cube of each
length to the volume is 2 to the N
this is the classical theorem this
version which means by Noah with many
many many applications but there a
stronger version of this theory this is
known as Minkowski second see of it what
is done here you just replace Lander one
by the product of the one over lender I
and since they form and monotonously
increasing sequence the right hand side
is smaller in general than the right
hand side here the result is considered
as a rather impersonal in German tier of
numbers and almost everybody has proven
it so these are just a couple it's
really a fascinating result from and at
least we can be sure it seems to be true
I mean because there are so many there
are so many different proofs
yeah it has also applications but may be
more on the theoretical side for
instance if you go to what is called
Mycoskie reduction and there's a called
so called finite sphere finiteness
earring then it is used there but also
in some more modern applications
additive combinatorics if you could look
at Fryman theorem and if you have sets
which has a small double doubling
constant then again at some point this
theorem shows up okay there's also a
lower bound
you see earth here of course you cannot
have a lower bound in terms of 1 over
lambda 1 to the end but here you have a
lower bound and this is of this type so
you get here a factor of 1 over N
factorial it's also best possible if you
look in general it's such a cross
polytopes the convex hull of plus minus
1 the unit vectors this is easy to prove
this prove you can prove by inclusion
the lower bound find such a nice cross
positive in your gun the upper bound
well you really I you have to work work
more ok and this was just a fascinating
theory of course the people were looking
for generalizations and extensions
and the first question is can you do
something like this
for arbitrary convex bodies why do we
need symmetry why of course we do it in
order to measure the successive minimize
clear but can we have such a theorem of
makovski I portray convex body so is it
a bound on the volume of convex body so
that we know it's a volume is bigger
than this then it always contains the
lattice point obviously not because you
can always have a convex body between
two parallel lattice hyper planes and
the volume can be arbitrary large so you
have to make a trick and one trick is
here you look at the symmetry of a
convex body what does it mean suppose we
have a convex body an arbitrary like
this triangle here okay then you look at
minus case or the reflection of the
origin this is minus K then you take the
Minkowski sum of K and minus K so you
add minus K to all the points here in K
you get this hexagon here and you then
you scaled by 1/2 then you get again a
symmetric convex body clear by
definition and if K is symmetric itself
then this is the same as K so this case
some of the symmetry associate to the
body called convex body K and then you
can basically easily generalize the
theorem of Mycoskie to arbitrary convex
bodies the trick here is this is still
the volume of K but here we measure the
success minimap with respect to the
symmetry this is best possible because
you can have a symmetric convex body and
for the upper bound here you have to you
have to observe that the volume of K is
not bigger than the volume of KC and
this is just an application of the
so-called theorem of pro makovski for
the lower bound you have to work you can
basically also do it by inclusions I
think that's so you can get something
like this but of course you might say
that's not fair because the extremal
bodies are again the symmetric body so
can we get really something for non
symmetric bodies but then we have to
make an assumption about the the origin
because we measure the success of minim
are starting at the origin somehow
then usually what the people do is they
assume suppose you have a convex body
and the centroid now is the origin so
the barycentre is the centroid whatever
and then you might also conjecture such
an inequality all what is known here let
me tell you the extremely cases in this
case would be really non symmetric
convex body the lower bound would be
attained for instance by this simplex
here convex all of the unit vectors and
the minus one vector and the upper bound
would be contained by you just take your
standard simplex scale it by n plus one
and then the the centroid is a point 1 1
1 1 1 1 and then you have to translate
it so that the centroid is the origin so
this is basically open all what we know
is that the lower bound is correct this
leads to a nice problem that you from a
geometric point of view it leads to a
nice problem that you have somehow to
you have to say something about convex
bodies with centered at the origin about
the volume and you know that they
contain certain n lattice points lattice
points that you understand what is the
minimum volume of a set of a convex set
containing these lattice points and
having the centrality and the upper
bound is true for N equals 2 by the way
this number here is e to the N basically
right Minkowski is 2 to the N this
number is e to the N but you deal with
arbitrary bodies so what you can do
there is a well-known result in convict
geometry by Milman and pajara you can
always find in your body K such a
assuming that the central is the origin
a symmetric body namely you just take
the intersection of K with minus K the
volume of this body is not too small and
if you then use this result together
with minkowski's result you get an upper
bound here for to the end instead of e
to the N it has been reasonably a little
bit improved
but okay and let me also point out why I
show you this because there's a very
classical conjecture by Earhart from 64
and this is somehow the non symmetric
analog of minkowski's result namely this
conjecture of Earhart phase
suppose I have a convex body with
centroid at the origin and I know now
the volume is greater or equal e to the
N side then it contains a non-trivial
lattice point and this is a somehow the
counterpart to the classical theory
moving cost now for bodies with centroid
at the origin and this is some classes
some it's known for simplicity so within
the class this was already shown by
arrow if you have the simplex then you
it is Stan and also in dimensional three
four bodies of revolution something like
this he did but I think not much okay
okay let me also briefly say something
else there is a very classical result a
very classical conjecture in geometry of
numbers which is called Davenport's
conjecture just want to show you it may
be for this I need that the entity of a
dentist lettuce packing okay I don't
want to go into the details what it is
but one way to define it is that you
look I mean forget this 2 2 divided by 2
to the N for a moment one way to define
it is you look for a linear image of
your body K and assume this is a
symmetric you look for a linear image of
your body K which has maximal volume
under all linear images which do not
contain interior lattice point then if
you divide it by 2 to the N then this
gives you the density of a dentist's
lattice packing this number is in
particular between 0 and 1 by the
theorem of Minkowski you know this gives
you something like optimal lattice
arrangement of your convex body but
since I have fixed the letters I have to
define it in this way and by definition
just by the definition of this Delta K
you get such an improvement of the first
theorem of Minkowski it's just a
definition because I taste the soup here
but this number is less than 1 in
particular for ball it is less than 2 to
the no square root 2 to the minus n to
the minus n so this can be really very
very small and then the classical and
then of course if you see this and then
you might also conjecture and this was
done by Dave and rod 46 in fact that you
can also get the second theorem of
makovski with this additional factor of
the density of identity but all what is
known here that is true for ellipsoid so
in general dimensions ellipsoid I mean
general dimensions and in the case N
equals 2 this was already shown by
minkovski when you were studying the
successive mini Marv it's known up to a
factor of square 2 to the N minus 1 by
shavod here and Rogers and it's also
known to be true by Woods
this is a beautiful contractor from a
geometric point of view it's really
beautiful but it seems to be seems to be
very hard now if you think again at the
successive minima then they say
something about the lattice points
inside your convex body right so you can
ask can you use them in order to say
something about the number of lattice
points in your convex body so can we
real place roughly speaking the volume
by the number of lattice points and this
G of K is now their so-called lattice
point enumerator and then many many
years ago in a joint work with you big
jerk village we observed that of course
you can get a kind of first theorem of
Minkowski now with respect to the
lattice points unfortunately we were
only able to prove this kind of second
theorem of makovski for the plane and we
also get a lower bound in the number of
in terms of the number of lattice points
in terms of the successive million why
is this I mean from my point of view
interesting because all these result
implies the corresponding results for
the volume because you can approximate
the volume by lattice points so they are
stronger than the volume results this
for the lattice points or if you would
know in this inequality in general for
arbitrary n then you get make another
proof a discrete proof of makovski
second theorem one successively and this
of course is the most interesting
problems I go I go to the symmetry so
this is different spot you scaled by 1/2
what do we know is I did it many years
ago you it's true up to a factor 2 to
the n minus 1 and the proof actually
relies on this observation if you
suppose this you take here the the floor
function of these numbers you are
interested in and you have some other
integers which are bigger or not like I
mean and they
excessively divisible so P I plus 1
divides P I then you get always such an
inequality now you can easily find some
numbers P I satisfying all these
requirements but they are also not
bigger than 2 times Q I then later based
on this approach vámanos Malygos is here
and it proved this to roughly speaking
square root 3 to the n minus 1 and
improved this four dimensions not bigger
than now for all dimensions greater not
less than or equal three not bigger this
is the state of this conjecture and but
it's much harder to I mean harder to
deal with lattice points because they
are rather district they don't behave
nice or whatever if you work with a
volume life is now he also proved it for
a lip sort so now let me introduce
another concept of convex bodies are
from convex geometry I think most of you
have seen it this is a polar body so if
I have a convex body in RN and they look
at all the points why so that the inner
product is not bigger than 1 for all
points out of K then what I get is
called the polar body of K so if you
like LP balls then the fuller body
opener people is a cue ball where 1 plus
P 1 over P goes 1 over Q is 1 if you
take a I mean if you take a ball then
the polar body is a ball if you take a
cube so there's maximum norm so to speak
then the polar body is a cross polytope
the other one norm so this is a
well-known concept there's also a very
well-known problem relating relating the
volume of K and the volume of the polar
body this goes yeah there's an old
problem so what you know what we know is
that the volume of K times the volume of
the polar body is related
bounded from below and by above by these
two numbers and one of the very
interesting conjectures in convex
geometry is that this c1 has to be 4
this is known as malla conjecture it is
known to be true for N equals 2 because
mala proofed it in the plane with with
the 4 and there is a reason to result by
ye and data that the malecon check sure
is also true for N equals 3 I will use
it later on now you can also look at the
success of minima of your polar body and
in particular you look if you look at
the first successive minimum of the
polar body of K minus K then this has a
very nice geometric interpretation this
is known as a lattice width so if you
take here
intro vector and we assume that it is
not a multiple of another internal
vector say then like this a-here what
you count here this maximum is roughly
speaking the number of parallel lattice
hyper planes and with this normal which
intersect your body plus minus 1 I don't
know ok and so what you are going to do
- to show here or what you want to
determine here is a minimal amount of
parallel lattice hyperplane which
intersect your body so here we have five
say in this direction that's not a good
direction if you would do it parallel to
the coordinate planes when you get to
three
okay what I also want to point out this
name was already mentioned implicitly in
the be conjecture name is Bernard shake
and bonacic also proved that you have
such a relation among the successive
minima of K and the polar of case the
lower bound is easy to see the upper
bound is hard to prove okay you're
absolutely right yes this is everything
right okay
now next question can we say something
about the polar if you look at the at
the successive member of your cooler
body say now we take again this symmetry
and can we get some say something about
the volume and the lattice point
enumerator then the upper bones are easy
to prove because this is follows
basically buying inclusion assuming that
K let us assume that K is symmetric then
of course if we take internal points
contained in a lambda 1 K star then we
know that our body cade the original
body due to the definition of the polar
bodies contained in this parallelepiped
and so you get this volume bound it's
clear and you get also this bound on the
number of lattice points because if you
take your lattice point then the inner
product with all these Anna lattice
points of course it's an intro and these
lattice points are linearly independent
so you get at most so many you get a
smooth so many letters for so lower
bounds upper bounds are easy
what about lower bounds well again
there's a conjecture again very just for
K equals minus K this is again a
conjecture by malar that you have such a
lower bound which is quite natural again
yeah not not again but if combination of
mother's volume conjecture plus
minkowski's control plus minkowski's
upper bound implies this balance
this is somehow weaker than the I mean
if you would know that malos volume
conjecture is true then this is true I
don't know actually he also gave a proof
of it but it was based on the wrong
proof of the Malheur conjecture which
were some where in the literature at
some point but I don't know why he was
interested I mean he was also working a
lot in geometry of numbers and then I
think it is quite natural and maybe he
was also of course interested in the
polar body I mean maybe it's quite
natural to come up with this conjecture
so but even the weaker inequality so if
you replace you everything by the first
successes minimum to the end is not
known for any creator equals thing for
and this is a nice geometric inequality
so suppose we scale we assume that you
can scale everything here suppose that
we assume that lambda 1 is equal to 1
then this means if you think of this
lattice with then this means whenever
you have a lattice hyperplane at level 1
so you have an interval vector a x
equals 1 so hey is the literal vector
and you look at the hyperplane a X inner
product equals 1 then this hessed
has to have the point in common with
your convex body so if you assume that
you have such a convex body submit the
convex body then the conjecture says the
volume is at least the volume of a cross
point so this is also kind of nice
counterpart to mean Communion courses
but it's I mean it is very very easy to
I think formulate and to understand but
it's not known I mean everything is
somehow asymptotically known that you
can play the games we know that malla
conjecture is asymptotically true by
moving on Millman and
so is that c1 I mean I mentioned there
was a c1 c1 to the N and we are looking
for c1 equals four and I think it is
known if it is I to the N or I don't
know what is right if you don't care
about the constants like for Mahler you
expect the worst case to be the cube or
some product of cubes in that one balls
or something yeah so the people expect
these Henner polytopes yes yeah and here
you're also you're you're expecting the
cross pollito just across planet oh yeah
so yeah it's sort of like the analog of
like for Minkow reverse Minkowski if you
think the worst answer is a 10 here it's
like you know you've got the cube and
the cross polytope and they should you
know well I mean there's a general
theorem and convex geometry the extra
misers are always nice yes
okay so now I have to a little bit let
me just mention there is also of case in
the general case if you just work with
arbitrary convex bodies then there's a
and he proved it for N equals two you
can of course also try to do this now
with all the successive minima and we
try to do something there and a joint
work with se-joo we prove such an
inequality so you get 3 over 2 n equal
to lambda1 lambda2 last an additional
factor depending on the difference
between de between lambda 2 and lambda 1
and whatever and when we arrived with
this result we gave up to think about
higher dimensions because it was too
complicated for us I mean to imagine
what can be extremely solutions so if
you replace the lambda 1 to the N up
there with the product of the lambda i's
here then you have another conjecture
stronger would would be stronger yeah
it's not that a stronger one is going to
be false no no no no no I mean this is a
little bit stronger even than this
conjecture in N equals two if you
replace this by lambda 1 and lambda 2
because you get here an additional term
depending on the difference between
lambda 2 I mean they have really all
this also this conjecture of market is
really beautiful from geometric folder
you have all the intersecting whenever I
take a lattice hyperplane it has to
intersect and then you can something
about the volume but it seems to be
difficult to to to approach so finally
let me speak a little bit about what we
call pecking minima and they are defined
in covering minimum of cannon and low
bus and this is based on an ongoing
joint work with Matias Uwe and takes you
into this end I have to speak a little
bit about general lattices so I mean
it's clear that the definition of the
success of minima I can generalize to
arbitrary lattices you just replace it
and I also have to need an eye all so
need a notation for the set of all K
dimensional linear lattice subspaces of
my lattice set n denoted by L subsets
all in your subspace is generated by K
linearly independent lattice and then we
were interested in the following which
we call a row I of K just think about
symmetric convex body otherwise you
always get you this
KC so what we do is for a given n minus
1 dimensional lattice hyperplane we look
at the lattice which we get if we
project set N onto the orthogonal
complement this perp which gives you an
Ida mention lattice and we do the same
with our convex body K and then we to
look at the first successive minimum and
now we maximize this over all n minus I
dimensional lattice hyperplane what we
do is this number is so to speak the
smallest number o such that all
projections of Rho times KC long n minus
1 dimensional lattice planes contain a
non-trivial lattice point of this AI
dimensional lattice
but this immediately implies the Dro I
cannot be bigger than the N minus I plus
first successes minimum of KC because if
your scale your body KC with this number
then this body contains n minus I plus 1
linearly independent lattice points and
on a projection along and n minus 1
dimensional lattice planes these lattice
points cannot all go to the kernel
so one lattice point has to survive this
is one can we get an an in particular of
course in particular I'm sorry in
particular if I equals end you get
exactly the first successive minimum now
I'm running a little bit out of time
then let me don't give you the argument
just let me also point out at the end of
the day that these row I are exactly
between the sector's minima of K and the
successors of minimum of the polar body
that's why we're interested in these
guys so yet Rho I is I showed you and
here you have to a queue a little bit
more and in particular for I equals n
you get exactly lambda 1 and for I
equals 1 you get exactly the first
successes minimum of the pool of the
polar body and that's why we're
interesting and then they look nice but
they are not that nice in particular
they are not monotonously decreasing so
maybe from here from this definition you
might expect they're monotone this
decrease they are not because this would
imply that Rho 1 is bigger or equal Rho
n which gives you such an inequality on
the first successive minimum of KC and
KC star and this is known not to be true
this product can be as large as a
dimension
and of course using banner shakes staff
then you get also some bounce in in the
other direction but that's not very
interesting the the point for us was can
we say something about volume and
lattice points and of course you get
inequalities for the volume and of
course the upper bound is travel in the
sense the throw R is not bigger than the
n minus I plus first successive minimum
it's clear that this follows immediately
from in Koski theory but the lower bound
is stronger is no stronger but again the
lower bound due to this relation is
weaker than the conjectured one in the
malla if you do it with a polar body
because they are in between but our main
result actually in this way we were
interested you get something like this
you can bounce the number of lattice
points now by by by this two over Rho I
this is stronger then the obvious one
with the polar bodies but of course it's
still weaker than the one with which we
are looking for then the conjectured one
where we really have two successive mean
there are many more problems about this
packing minima but about the relations I
mean the ice one on how it is related to
the N minus first one of the polar body
and so on and but I'm pretty sure that
the people have studied somehow this
because it is very natural I mean if you
look at the covering minima of Canada
lavash which are not going to introduce
it's the same definition but instead of
lambda one you look at the covering
radius and do it with the projection
that is quite natural that you look look
at the first successive minimum okay and
I'm pretty sure that the people have
studied it but I'm not aware about some
literature so if you know something then
please let me know thank you for
attention
[Applause]
okay
so we'll break for lunch and then resume
I think at two o'clock all right thank
Martin
[Applause]